ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we're doing a quick one this
week we're we're running around uh and
we're on tour right now so we
we're not gonna be with you for the hour
we're probably gonna do closer to 45
minutes if you have a problem with that
you can go watch something else we don't
care uh colin powell is dead uh
and it's very sad and he uh you know he
was uh uh the first uh black uh liar and
he lied
to the un he was the first black
person who told a big lie about iraq and
he knew it was a lie
and we respect colin powell because
that's the game of politics is lying i
mean and he did it well
he was a leader and a legend and he did
many other things that were great but he
also you know
unfortunately you know dick cheney and
that that that crew of goblins
got him to go in and sell the iraq war
and people believed that i believed it i
was in you know like
uh 12th grade at the time 11th or 12th
grade and i thought that we had to go
into iraq and democratize the middle
east i believe that i was a closeted
gay cocaine addict
um and to me that logic made sense that
people in the middle east hated us
because we were free and we had to make
them free so that they would not hate us
anymore
and the way to do that was to go into
the country of iraq and get rid of
saddam hussein this is for you zoomers
out there this is what happened when i
was in high school you had coveted and
whatever
uh i had the uh the iraq war and the
iraq war was uh this war
where similar to afghanistan
um
that was going to fix all the problems
it was going to put pressure on iran
and all of these other anti-democratic
regimes and it was going to force them
uh to become
thriving
uh
societies
that respected the rule of law and the
rights of women and they were going to
become good trading partners and that's
really what it's about but colin powell
was essential in this because colin
powell went
to the u.n
and gave this very convincing speech
about saddam hussein
having weapons of mass destruction
and it was a black mark on an otherwise
pretty stellar career
um
and it's sad that he died of covet he
died because
uh he had a cancer that was attacking
his immune system
um he was fully vaccinated but that
doesn't really matter if you have a
cancer that's attacking
your immune system um
we'll see there's statements here to
pull we're recording this on the day
that he died we're a week early today
because we had to use the studio new
studios being built working with a new
realtor
very excited about that who seems to be
a little bit more on the ball
from what we uh understand we've had
very bad luck with realtors across the
board oh wow yeah yeah very bad luck
everything and
realtors
fall into two categories usually they
are um older menopausal women
uh that are suffering mild brain damage
from either a car accident or an
undiagnosed or self-diagnosed autoimmune
disorder
these women
are
usually
middle-aged mid-age they're
on their second marriage or
trying to keep the loveless first
marriage
and real estate for them might be a
second career or it may be a first
career that they kind of had
while they were raising their children
and
every new client
is a new husband for them
and they find a way to let every new
client down in the same way that they
let their husband down
over 30 years
and that's the what is this did you
pulled up this is an interesting
average age of an employed real estate
agent is 48. yeah the average age of an
employed real estate agent is 48 years
old so that's usually
it's a menopausal woman who's having hot
flashes
wants to [ __ ] ben
and i walk in behind him and go here's
the bad news i have all the money
and they basically make a big mess
out of everything you're trying to do
the other realtor is a young
chocular bro guy
who got into real estate because he
wants to crush it
he wants to [ __ ] crush it
and both of these people are incredibly
unhelpful when you're trying to get
something done
they're incredibly unhelpful the
menopausal woman deals
solely in the realm of emotions and says
things like
yeah oh
hmm
well
ah i believe what i think we can do
here's what and then the broly guy is
like yeah make it happen we're gonna
[ __ ] make it happen get it done
neither one of them gets it done
yeah there's 156 000 real estate agents
currently employed in the united states
53 percent are women
are men
it is a women-dominated field real
estate it is one of the fields that
women dominate as they should
many of them are very good at it but
many are not
and we've had some real tough run-ins
with real estate agents
you know my realtor out in palm springs
lovely woman lovely but fitz the
demographic of what i talked about
uh
then we had the real estate agent agora
hills remember her same thing oh yeah we
had the realtor in malibu
similar thing yes uh incredibly bad in
her job do these windows up and i don't
know i mean just a lazy
person you know that had no
understanding of what she was doing from
day to day and
you know then we had uh the woman in
texas who was good she was probably the
best of all of them but still not
perfect
from you know not not
perfect but good better right i found
the house though that's what you don't
realize when you when you use a real
estate agent you actually do most of the
work
you do all of the work you find the
house
you call them up and you go please god
can we not lose this like we've done
three other times
and they go no
not a problem we're gonna get it
don't worry tim i'm gonna make it happen
and
and and then sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't work but we're
excited because we're building out this
uh new studio that we're very excited
about to take us into the new era of the
tim dylan show
the post covered era the uh you know
wherever we are
and we'll be uh very happy there and
very excited about it
we're also i've just been hired at snl
and they've they've not announced that
so congrats to me
congratulations to me
but i
i was hired
and the sketch that i pitched
i'm not even kidding and i was shocked
that this got on the air but this sketch
that i i pitched
um was
a george floyd cooking
a cook-off
where people make food to honor the
memory of george floyd
i was shocked
that it was going to get on the but hey
i'm excited so we're doing that
uh next week over at saturday night live
and of course the sketch
is to
make fun of the
the way that activists promote
themselves
and not the cause
that they are promoting and nothing's
funnier to me than a bunch of
amateur chefs
making food
to commemorate the death of george floyd
that of course
a sad thing that he died tragic but the
sketch and i had to explain this
because you you don't get the benefit of
the doubt but i said well we have the
cbs show the activist what's really
funny let's start doing cooking
competitions where people are showing
their activism through food
and then the contestants can accuse each
other of being racist and appropriating
culture it's a lot of fun it's a great
idea for a sketch on saturday night live
so they hired me and we're making that
sketch next week george floyd cook-off
it's the opening sketch i'm very excited
about now the problem is the entire cast
will not be in it
so it's just me and lauren against the
entire cast there's a massive walk out
very similar to what's happened uh over
at the netflix uh massive walk out so
the entire snl castle so if you want to
be in it
just dm me
or show up
at snl guy i want to be in the george
floyd sketch and bring a gun
that's a joke
but i say bring a gun for safety what
else is going on here you told me a very
interesting thing about the uh
there's people at sea
there's a crew of people that were lost
at sea yes yes so you know this this was
a february 2021 february 2021 after
three years abandoned at sea without pay
this oil tanker crew
is on the cusp of going home
this is a very interesting story when a
shipping company from the united arab
emirates which is why they by the way
why do they have the best airline i'll
tell you why do you know why because
it's fear
because if you work for emirates you
have a fear of [ __ ] up
when you work at delta or american there
is no fear
of [ __ ] up
but when you work at emirates i can't
say why this is but maybe it's because
the united arab emirates is a bit
stricter a bit harsher
with some of the punishments that are
doled out for many of the things that
people do
and there's something that is instilled
in the flight attendants where they just
do the right thing emirates is a
phenomenal airline united arab emirates
hits financial trouble in 2017 the
shipping company hit financial trouble
in 2017 and and abandoned and they
abandoned an oil tanker off the coast of
dubai now dubai is this modern
city that's kind of built on slave labor
and it's you know a lot of people are
pointing to this and saying this is uh
no good
now dubai is incredibly hot they have
like indoor
everything's indoors i think they have
indoor ski slopes like what they've been
able to do in dubai is amazing because
you can't really
spend that much time outside
uh
what do they have is this an indoor ski
slope yeah and their ski slopes i mean
they have everything here they have
everything in dubai everything you could
want
inside because
what is the average temperature in dubai
it's very hot
so what you have to do is spend a lot of
your time
inside
it's very very hot yes september it's
102. so forget i mean the summer forget
it
and
but the city
they've used a lot of what they consider
slave labor to build these very tall
very luxurious buildings and they have
been criticized for that heavily
so now they abandoned a shipment company
they ran into trouble and they abandoned
this oil tanker left a small crew aboard
they were stranded at sea
without pay or away home we're talking
2017.
those men have been on the tanker ever
since
but a chance at repatriation for the
five remaining crew seems to be finally
within grasp the owner told us please
wait i want to sell the ship and after i
will clear the salaries well that's nice
remembers nae wynn who came to work as a
chief engineer on the mt iba eba from
his home in myanmar so we are waiting
waiting waiting
be patient be patient
so wind started to work on the tanker
2017 a few months before the owner it's
amazing to me that people could just
just through the whole pandemic
through the entire pandemic these guys
are stuck
on an oil tanker
it's kind of worked out well
if you think about like everyone's gonna
go and blame the guys they're gonna say
you shouldn't have done this
but really
i love the quote all's well that ends
well
and if you think about this these people
have been socially distanced
away from others
during a global pandemic
how are they getting food
somebody said that in the article they
go without money how can they eat with
no money how do we manage how is this
i don't understand how this is happening
do you understand how they're eating i
i'm assuming they're fishing i'm looking
at the the gentleman they're probably
fishing over the over the board and they
might have cans of of food you know but
the only collateral they have it says
the only collateral they have is the
ship itself so that's why they don't
abandon it because the the company you
know wants to get the ship back
so they they they're trying to get paid
you know
well can the company just hire people to
go on there and kill them and take the
ship i suppose so i believe that's the
next step
but i mean i understand what they're
saying
bowerman said his organization has been
supporting the crew through quote a
pretty grim existence but again it's
only one way to look at it
the men have been living in the same
clothes for months
washing in cold water or sea water and
relying on his charity for food so
someone's bringing them food out there
but couldn't they just get on a boat and
leave they don't have passports it says
so they're they they can't go anywhere
they can't you know so they're totally
stuck but a boat comes something drops
them off food and they can't get on this
boat and leave well i guess well the
thing
they want to get paid right so they are
key they're staying on the ship until
they get paid okay
the first thing is to make sure they've
got food they've got water they've got a
little bit of oil for the generators
the organization also wanted to quote be
physically present to listen to their
stories bring the news of home don't
even do that don't bring them any news
at home
try to ensure that their well-being is
looked after as much as possible so now
what what is going to happen here
says following the agreement over pay
the crew agreed agreed to stay on the
ship while towed to safety with hopes
that the repatriation process can begin
early next month so they eventually got
home and supposedly got supposedly got
paid
for their time at sea i smell a
movie
i think it would be a good film
to have these guys
on the boat
just
existing
but we've had too many films like that
already
we've had too many
so then it goes music barbecues wi-fi
managing morale for those idle did see i
bet they were having a little more fun
than they wanted to admit do you go gay
in that time in three years
a question do you
it's very odd
three years of no females do you go gay
because if this is a movie
it's got it it's got to just be about
gay
sex muslim gay sex
that would have to be the direction
hollywood goes in muslim guys and
they're like i have this religion but i
also want to [ __ ] and there's no women
around so it just becomes like a hot
kind of orgy
and that seems like
the way that the movie would would go
it would be like brokeback mountain but
these guys in an oil tanker
for three years who can't bathe
you know just kind of pounding
on an oil tanker
well i wish them the best god bless
you had an experience
everybody is looking uh in life
for everybody plans everything everybody
has a plan and this is the real problem
i noticed
in between my generation where our
parents did not care about us at all
and subsequent generations where people
were you know what do they call them
helicopter parents they were always
involved they were helping their child
strategize
every single moment of their life
there's some happy medium there
and many parents listen to the show
there's a happy medium between my
parents where they just dropped you off
at pizza hut and said go get molested
and the people that were planning every
single moment of your life
because really you can't plan
everything sometimes you're going to end
up
on a ship
having sex with a man and you didn't
know you were gay but you have three
years
it's [ __ ] time and you know what that
means is blue chew get your dick hard
b-l-u-c-h-e-w blue chew it's got the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis but it's in a chewable form you
can take it any time day or night fuller
empty stomach you go in there eat the
pill and you're ready to [ __ ]
blue chew is everything it's discreet
it's online medical professionals give
you a diagnosis it's shipped right to
your house you don't have to stand in
line you don't have to look at the
person who became a pharmacy technician
who you went to school with who's better
than you who stayed in college who
didn't get invited to the party and you
thought actually getting invited to the
party made you better but it didn't it
made that guy better because now he's
got a wife and he's got a house and it's
not a great house and the wife's okay
but you've got nothing and you're living
with your mother and your dick doesn't
even work because you've spent so many
time uh you know watching porn and
jerking off you've completely ruined
yourself and this guy has just living a
stable life as a pharmacist and he's
doing fine but fine to you looks great
because you are not doing fine and
you're still pumping it out in your
[ __ ] basement you have a horrible
porn addiction you're not addicted to
drugs thank god because you can't even
afford them you're a low-level grifter
you have nothing going on you work at
telemarketing trying to sell people [ __ ]
you were trying to do solar panels for a
while you bum cigarettes off 15 year
olds at the mall you are a disgusting
hunk of [ __ ] but the only thing that
you're able to do is pump come out of
your dick into some slower who you find
so god at least do that well bluee2.com
for more details and important safety
information we thank bluechu for
sponsoring the podcast promo code td
bluetooth promo code td
and we've got a special deal for our
listeners try bluetooth free when you
use our promo code td at checkout just
pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code td to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast
watch gang dude i'm becoming a watch guy
are you a watch guy i am there's two
types of guys in the world there are
watch guys and there are guys whose
dicks don't work
if you're a watch guy you get puss
sloppy wet puss
if you're not a what have you ever seen
a woman have sex with a man without a
watch
not that i can recall or a man a man
will not have sex with you without a
watch no one's gonna [ __ ] you without a
watch join watch club they've given over
500 rolexes away they give a tag away
every tuesday a rolex every friday and a
seiko every saturday
treat yourself with 70 off retail a plan
for every price point keep every watch
you can't have one watch you need
watches for different times you need a
watch for when your brother tells you
that he's leaving his wife because you
love his wife and you want to [ __ ] his
wife and you don't really like him but
you can't but will you you wrestle with
that you have this crazy fantasy of
[ __ ] brother you need a what maybe
that's a seiko i don't know but you need
a watch for that moment you need to
watch for the moment when you go in and
tell your boss you deserve more and you
need a raise and he says no you don't
you're not getting one and you don't
quit even though you said you were gonna
quit you march right back to your desk
and you sit there and you do the same
[ __ ] you've done for three years because
you don't want to bet on yourself you
don't have the work ethic and the
intelligence to make it work on the
outside so you go back to your little
cubicle prison you need a watch to look
at to see when lunch is certain times
you need certain watches get a watch
whenever the hell you want it monthly
quarterly whenever the hell you want go
to watchdang.com and use the promo code
tim for 20 off all plans that's
w-a-t-c-h-g-a-n-g.com promo code tim
save 20 that's watchgang.com promo code
tim
teen girls are showing up to the doctor
with ticks experts think anxiety
depression and tick tock could be
playing a role i have motor tick
syndrome something that i've had since
i'm a kid i have tics i have eye tics i
have all kinds of tics um if i don't get
sleep or if i'm eat a lot of sugar and
when have i done that never thank god
i've never done that
but if if if i do these things if i
don't
care for my overall health the ticks
will get worse i do not have the vocal
component of tourette's where i would
yell words that would get me uh kicked
off this
site where you're watching the show i
don't have that but
people do tourette syndrome is a genetic
nervous system disorder
can cause ticks
repetitive involuntary movements or
sounds it mostly impacts boys and the
tics physically start when a person is
young and then develop over time but
women get them as well and now women's
tics and you you may know more than me
but i read this article they seem that
they're being exacerbated
by the cut meaning made worse
by the content they're watching on
tick-tock
and tick-tock ironically
tick
tock
so these people that have tourette's are
watching people on tick-tock and just
stroking out is that what's going on
here yeah it says doctors noted that
what's happening isn't necessarily true
but a functional movement it's a
functional movement disorder because
kids want to fit in they want to fit in
they want a community people all over
the world want a community whether it's
hot people or rich people or [ __ ]
activists or poets or [ __ ] some dumb
hick they all want a community and
even people
that any community will do
there the standards for what community
you end up in are not high
people don't care so if you have to
have ticks
as part of
the initiation
to get into the community go hey you
take i-tick
we're like this
so
i don't understa so some kids have
pulled out their phones and they show
the doctors uh tick tock and it's full
of these tourette's cooking and alphabet
challenges
now i don't know what those are but i
imagine it's people with tourette's
cooking and just screaming like
different slurs and how's that calm and
cooking everything because it's funny
it's funny when you make an omelette
[ __ ]
it's funny
that's funny i'd watch that but i
wouldn't because then maybe i'd tick
more that's the game and then i can't
blame you you know nobody would believe
people don't even believe if i just
started saying horrible things nobody's
going to say oh yes tourette no one
would care it's mild tourettes and i
can't get away with anything um like i
have mild homosexuality my homosexuality
is not pronounced but it's it's
effective when it needs to be i i have
sex with men but that doesn't that's not
really what being gay is anymore being
gay is not really having sex with men
it's really dying your hair it's gone
from having sex with men to dyeing your
hair which is much easier to do having
sex with with men
you have to put a a penis in your mouth
like an entire penis or in your butt or
you have to put your penis in someone
else's butt it's a it's a it's an
activity
and dyeing your hair is is relatively
simple you would die in a purple or a
blue or a green and then not have sex
with men women or anyone but you can be
queer
you can be queer and go i'm queer and
you go well what does that mean and they
go
well i don't i reject the gender binary
and i reject i'm pansexual you go well
what does that mean well i have sex with
anyone well who have you had sex with
well not anyone really
maybe i have but usually as i'm
pansexual but i'm not having sex
with a person of the same sex i just
have sex with my boyfriend but i'm a
white woman with blue hair so i'm queer
so it's interesting that i have a very
mild form of homosexuality it has not
progressed into uh dyed hair and the
rejection of the uh actual sex acts
because that's the
that's the heightened form of
homosexuality where you you reject
any and all sexual contact but you
replace it uh with uh fun
uh glitter and hairstyles and things
like that um
some kids have pulled out their phones
they show the doctors hey i'm watching
people with tourette's cook and do
alphabet challenges the jerusalem post
reported that these disorders can be
treated doctors suggest kids take a
social media break
isn't it time to take a break
if social media is giving you tourette
syndrome
isn't it time to take a break
if social media
is giving you an involuntary tick
disorder
it might be time
to take a break and i don't know the
like i don't think these kids are
forcing these ticks
this is actually something that is
happening to them right
well you also see communities on tick
tock of people who claim they have like
asperger's or autism right and they love
to uh
what's it called
where they shake i forget what they call
it whether they do this together i don't
know because it's sensory overload so
it's girls jumping on their bed doing
this because they love to have autism so
it's a lot of like fame they see that
these people are very popular and a lot
of these things are feigned
to be just like interesting you know so
i i think a lot i think a lot of this is
probably fake right i think we've gotten
to a point now where technology i've
made this point at nauseam has flattened
everybody to the point where people
aren't really developing personalities
anymore so the only way to distinguish
themselves is to get a disorder and get
it quick
get a disorder and get it quick anxiety
depression tourettes don't be picky
aspergers anything get on the spectrum
and stay there that seems to be if you
want a social life the best thing you
can do as a child is to develop some
type of disorder on now in the real
world that doesn't work as well but
online people actually gravitate to each
other on the basis of shared horror
shared pain shared problems
nobody online is like i love this and
the other person's like i love that
let's together
usually it's like i am suffering i am
also suffering i hate this i also hate
this let's form a bond and all of these
kids their meaningful social
interactions are primarily online so
what they're doing is they're going
online and they're saying who else has a
problem and certain problems look more
fun than others and i mean and i'm not
saying that these problems aren't real
and they don't exist and that people
don't genuinely have them i'm saying
that this word that nobody likes to use
social contagion everyone hates that
because usually when people talk about
it they talk about a lot of the women
that are now identifying as non-binary
and they're saying you know there are
people that say how many people are
non-binary and the entire class at
oberlin college raises their hand and
you go statistically it's impossible
i come from a time where being a [ __ ]
was special
now not so much now
part of
this social contagion word that people
don't like is because it was used
against gay people and against all you
know we're saying this isn't really who
you are you're just doing this to piss
off tip or gore or something i don't
know remember al gore's fat wife who
didn't like marilyn manson i don't know
if she had a problem with gays but
whatever she didn't like marilyn manson
and i thought he was cool back then not
so much now it's gone in a weird
direction i can't fully support but
antichrist superstar was a good album if
you were a seventh grade goth closeted
gay uh guy who was just starting to
discover uh that you could crush up
pills and put them up your nose
now
people hate that word social contagion
but we're social animals
we exist in a social space
and all of the things we do primarily
are to make ourselves
achieve a level of comfort
and then there are people out there that
don't want that level of comfort and
push through it and those are the people
genuinely not always but generally can
accomplish things because to accomplish
things you have to push yourself out of
a comfort zone but everything we're
doing socially is to arrange
our lives to be comfortable and having
friends and having social um
commitments to people
is a way to be
comfortable
and you know who does it the nelq boys
do it they do it very well and they have
built this community amongst college
kids who just want to drink party get
[ __ ] up get their dicks wet
i mean they want to have fun and my
favorite now kid is steve will do it
support him now before he's in a mexican
jail
steve will do it
he's the world's number one youtube
channel i don't know if that's true but
it might be
and if you're drunk enough it is
steve is great he's always giving people
teslas he loves watches he makes
bazillions of dollars and he's part of
the collection of milk they're a
canadian group internet pranksters if
you will
they go and have a lot of fun they get
to drive around and and drink and do
coke in front of the cops and because
they're white none of them get shot it
would be hard for a black group to pull
off some of their videos right it would
end with minnesota being burned down
because that's just the reality of of of
race in the country i didn't do it
but this is unfortunate right there
isn't really a black milk is there can
you be a black milk can you just go
around and pretend to have cocaine on
you if you're a black guy probably not
see
candace owens would say you can should
be like you could absolutely be a black
now you could be a black now
i think you can
steve is one of the biggest he's got one
of the biggest emerging fashion brands
baby
with full send they send me stuff look
at this hat
go to fullsend.com to sign up for
exclusive merge drops everything is
currently sold out and you don't want to
miss out on any more full send
exclusives
a lot of the young guys love
that while we're doing these ads and
they're signing up
lastly go right now to steve will do its
youtube channel and see what the hubbub
is about for yourself he drops new
videos every single thursday go to his
youtube channel right now see what he's
doing what is he up to one of my
favorite things he did was he's standing
in a vip line in a casino and a woman
doesn't know who he is and goes why are
you in that line and he turns around and
goes shut the [ __ ] i'd be stupid [ __ ]
so it's fun stuff like that
bradley martin is hiding brian laundry
surprising david dobrik with a tesla
yeah
well he's also doing philanthropy with
takashi 69 that's right they go around
and help uh young drunks
secure drugs and alcohol for themselves
getting a happy ending massage
i opened a free food truck in compton
i raced my lamborghini for 200 000.
i almost died with stevo
i'm dating a beauty beautiful 31 year
old latina woman and he's young steve
will do it he's like a young person how
old is this guy i believe he's like 22.
he's 22. he's young and he's a very
successful guy and he's been very kind
to us here at the show
he's been very nice to us and he's 24
22. 22 he's always trying to help us out
and this goes to show you not every 22
year old
with
a a drinking problem and mild autism is
gonna be
as successful as this guy
it's it's not gonna happen you know what
i mean
you have to really put in the work and
that work will kill you
most people who try to do what steve
will do it does will die
truly
they will die so the fact that this guy
has not only remained alive but thrived
is amazing so go
to his website steve will do it right
yeah just his youtube channel that's
what he's really s t e v e will do it on
youtube go to steve will do it on
youtube and subscribe
keeps
you need your hair
how do you do it do you get a wig do you
have some weird surgery no you keep the
hair that you have right now if you
start with keeps they will preserve the
hair that you have on your head that is
so important because you're keeping your
real hair all the other stuff looks fake
keeps is great discreet packaging proven
results they offer a simple stress-free
way to keep the hair that you have on
your head convenient virtual doctors
consultations medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home keeps
us more five-star reviews than any of
his competition guys prevention is key
treatments could take four to six months
so you gotta act now every uh ad we have
in the show supports the show they
support comedy the owners of these
companies are fans of comedy and the
type of comedy that we do it's important
that you support them if you are losing
your hair it's time to start with keeps
so if you're ready to take action to
prevent hair loss go to keeps.com
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon to
receive your first month of treatment
for free that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon to
get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash tim dillon
healthcare's crazy we know it we talk
about it all the time
sadly we do not have a government that's
going to guarantee people health care
certainly not in the short term
so we have things like crowd health it
can make it a little better
i mean half of americans are on a high
deductible insurance plan on the hook
for thousands of dollars of deductibles
co-pays sky-high premiums
i mean it's bad it's the leading
reason people go bankrupt
crowd health is not health insurance but
it is a better way to pay medical
expenses it's a community of people who
are tired of paying for a broken system
so it's a nice place we can go get a
simple flexible affordable way to pay
for your health care being in the crowd
health community can save hundreds of
dollars monthly and put thousands of
dollars back in your pocket membership
is a monthly subscription starter stop
when it's convenient for you
simple and transparent pricing
customized to your needs crowd health
lowers your monthly health care costs
and you can see any doctor you want
using their app find nearly any doctor
in the country ranked from one star to
five star scan bills throw them away
crowd help will take it from there press
a button to receive virtual care anytime
anywhere this is a health community it
allows people to get virtual care to
help manage their medical debt it's it's
great it's a community of health
conscious members who want to get and
stay healthy in return for lower prices
crowd health gets rid of insurance
middlemen and passes the savings along
to its members 100
of your monthly membership pays for
actual health care costs helping the
whole crowd health community
stay healthy while
keeping more money in your pocket
crowd health is able to offer amazing
prices because of its community health
conscious members
crowd is not health insurance it's
community powered alternative terms and
conditions apply but just go to
crowdhealth.com
fit
use promo code tim dillon at sauna join
crowdhealth.com fit promo code tim
dillon at sign up but for a limited time
our listeners will get their first month
free and if you're a member after you've
been a member crowd health will include
a fitness wearable that's 30 days to try
risk free plus a fitness wearable it's a
win-win
okay that's it
do you have any plans for the uh
halloween i know it's coming up and you
know october is a great month and many
people are excited about uh halloween is
you because you were at a jesus uh
school were you allowed to participate
in halloween uh yeah but it was it's
very innocent like you know you dress up
like a little uh like a little skeleton
and you just get candy it wasn't like uh
like you went to haunted houses and
stuff in long island right well we would
go sometimes to things like a hayride or
a haunted house right yeah and nothing
like that too satanic my neighbors
didn't read harry potter you know people
were weird about that people were weird
about it
and you were able to just but you would
go trick-or-treating yeah yeah who would
you go with just uh my mom and my dad
and they would bring you
trick-or-treating um
we'd go in the neighborhood in the
neighborhood and they would what would
you get
you get the the the the classics you get
you get reese's cups you get
butterfinger you get twix here's the
deal folks
you need to have if you're gonna do a
halloween bowl of candy reese's is the
best it's the it's it's a peanut butter
cup that's number one it's really the
number one candy i believe go look at
the candies ranked look at the rankings
of the candies i'm not a huge candy
person but reese's is amazing you gotta
have the little bags of m m's
you gotta have the little butterfingers
you maybe also you gotta have the little
hershey's where it's like special dark
and uh milk chocolate the little
hershey's things let's start at number
one well yeah what is the number one
ranked candy in america
yeah reese's peanut butter cups yeah
they just are this is specifically for
halloween so you're right on the money
with that here's the thing about the
reese's peanut butter cup it's kind of
the perfect candy
when my parents told me that they were
getting divorced because they didn't
love each other anymore
and it surprised me because i thought
all the fighting and the screaming and
sleeping in separate bedrooms meant that
things were going well but when they
told me that they didn't want to be a
family anymore but they were going to
live together
and uh have a very painful two-year
period of figuring out who got aunt
gussie's coffee table
i took solace in the peanut butter cup
which is great if you freeze it if you
put a peanut butter cup in the
refrigerator or freezer it's great
they're great in ice cream they're just
phenomenal they are the best candy by
far you and your wife got a bowl of
horrible things to give to children
that's not true
they didn't have reese's they don't have
eminem but we had we don't have
hershey's peanut butter snickers which
are good dude they're not nothing twix
is number two on this list we had twix
which you you uh
you're ridiculous you're a child and
you're eating twix
twix's campaign was like never for
children isn't it
what was wait what was it well no that
was kitkat kid cat was you need a break
yeah
yeah but it was like kick cat i think
it's from my mother likes kit kat i
think kit kats for like older people
yeah
twix's slogan is try both pick a side
[Music]
okay interesting i don't know that
that's the one to have in this political
climate huh but it's kind of sexy and
fun
try both pick a side it's like i'm not
picking a side
how about that
but it's exciting times here you know uh
with uh halloween
right around the corner remember the
gang in this initiation myth but maybe
it wasn't a myth
where people were worried
that if you went out on halloween
uh people and gangs
were going to kill you
because then they could get into the
gang
this was the thing that white
suburbanites yes
were like it was on their radar
that halloween now by the way it all
these myths
come from something
so
there's there there has to be some truth
to the idea that there is something
going on on halloween
i'm checking it on snopes well snopes is
a cia front
but it is yeah i know kind of is yeah
but they cite this up until recently
snopes was like jeffrey epstein's a math
teacher like
snopes is full of [ __ ]
[ __ ] listening to snopes
i'm just saying it has to co it doesn't
mean that the level of like satanic
panic where people get crazy yes but
were there was there some
child molestation going on
indisputably
it was happening
and with some of those people evil and
occult and whatever
for sure but yes did it go crazy to the
point where like tipper gore's running
around going
hey
you know pantera and marilyn manson and
ozzy osbourne like yeah it went crazy
but so i think the halloween uh gang
initiation
has to come from somewhere well it says
like here like in 2008 was a busy year
for the gang initiation week concept
because in the days before halloween in
oa two men were arrested in newark for a
drug and gang-related shooting rampage
that left two dead and an intelligence
report by the virginia state police
presented a possible scenario in which
the bloods would target law enforcement
on halloween with an ambush precipitated
by a low-level gang member following a
call to the police about a domestic
disturbance or a street fight right i
heard that too that they were going to
go after cops
and that they were going to yeah this
they don't seem to materialize no i was
always told that like on halloween
people would drive around without their
headlights off and if you flash them to
warn them that their headlights were off
then they would turn around and chase
you down and kill you well this is all
part of these gang initiation myths and
then there was oh you're going to get
people are going to poison your candy
remember that they were like don't
accept an apple which is
i get it yeah they're like remember that
there was a story where there's like
razor blades in an apple
yeah i wonder if that was urban myth
it might have been i love the idea of
americans telling their fat children to
not accept the fruit
don't you accept an apple
you take
sneakers
reeses
oh there's twix there's a whole
wikipedia for poisoned candy myths we're
a very terrified country
we like fear
fear
is what unites us
and halloween
is a great time for people
to be afraid
of losing the family members that they
don't really care about anyway
it's a very good time for that
and this was a boomer thing they were
like everybody's going to kidnap you
poison your candy gangs are good this is
how i grew up
and they they don't realize now they
don't understand why everybody's uh has
anxiety and depression and everybody's
paranoid they're like there's a white
van that's driving around the community
who's gonna kidnap you and [ __ ] you
and then
the gang is gonna initiate you're gonna
be part of a gang initiation when you
get shot in the head
on halloween if you haven't died from
your poison apple verse by the way this
is straight out of like
uh what's the one with the poison apple
snow white yeah yeah this is straight
out of like a grimm's fairy tale that
there are people poisoning candy
now i'm sure a few people did that maybe
no no no in fact uh this just gained
credence during the industrial
revolution so it seems to be xenophobic
because it says when food production
moved out of the home or local area
where it was made in familiar ways by
known and trusted people to strangers
using unknown ingredients and unfamiliar
machines and processes so as soon as it
wasn't local anymore people were going
you don't know who made that you don't
know why
why haven't xenophobic people continue
with that and like like why aren't they
talking about poison burritos
because people are too fat yeah i guess
they love they you can slander an apple
you can't slander an empanada people go
i don't care i don't care if it's
polishing it's good it's warm and i can
hold it in my hand
i love the apples took a beating
like yeah they're they're uh poisoning
the apples there's razor blades in the
fruit
there's uh
the produce is gonna kill you don't i
love it it's all the things we're told
are just horrible don't need anything to
start in the package
don't eat anything that's that highly
processed food
you look at the corporation that made
that food before you ate it
i'm gonna give out
celery sticks this year that have been
dipped in fentanyl
i want to be the first person to
actually poison people on halloween
we should set up a video
where
like the door opens and i just give kids
healthy food
and have them reject it
because it's poison
my mom said that's poison i'm like it's
a salad
it's poison
what is that it's radicchio that's
poison
gave me a cadbury cream egg or whatever
i mean that's for easter
but
it's an unhealthy country what do you
want me to do
if a big news story happens this week
we'll address it on the patreon we
wanted to do
a video episode my my i wish the best to
everybody here that's uh
suffering from involuntary tick
disorders from their use of social media
there is a time when perhaps we should
put the phone down
how bad is this gonna get are there
gonna be people that are like actually
getting cancer
to fit in when will this end well did
you see all the videos of the people
faking the side effects of the coba
vaccine
well i've seen some of that yeah yeah
um but i i think there are real side
effects but i don't i don't know if
people are filming right yeah
like some of them are like this yeah
it's like
all right
but here's the other thing
um
here's the other thing i was thinking
about what were we just talking about
before you interrupted
with a covered vaccine about the tick
tock uh
symptoms that girls were having
yeah about social media
um
oh yeah i never liked you know when
someone got cancer and then everyone
shaved their head
i think that's patronizing
like i i didn't love that
and i know that's a heartwarming thing
that most people are supposed to love
it's the same with the dog videos i
never liked like the dog
uh is happy that the guy's back for the
soldiers back from iraq i'm like you
adopted this animal and then abandoned
it to go to kill children in iraq
the dog has no idea what you've been
doing if the dog knew how many children
and dogs you killed
probably right
dogs can't judge
i never liked those videos i never liked
the bald head
where we all shave our head
well we're shaving it in solidarity what
i don't understand i guess it makes
young kids feel better there's something
nice about it
i do you know like every now and then
they'll be like this dad got his son's
birthmark tattooed on him
to make his son feel better and i go i
get it there's something sweet about
that but the kid's eventually gonna grow
up and go this was dumb
right
you know
like my dad's never copied anything that
i like i wouldn't tell my dad to go out
and be successful
people have to have their own identities
timdylandcomedy.com it's a quick one
today but last week we went 117. so
that's it it's you get what you get here
timdalecomedy.com i'm not reading all
the dates there's a lot of dates
come see us live
it's gonna be a lot of fun
we're doing stand-up comedy well i am
it's a tremendous event
we're all over the country
after this tour we're going to the uk
we're announcing a week-long
tour in the uk we're going to be in
london and and ireland and i believe
scotland we're still firming up those
details but it's going to be good for
everyone
everyone's going to love it
it's gonna be fun
and eventually we're gonna go to
australia when they open that place up
but i mean they just went full
fascist mode in australia
amazing you would never think it would
be australia
you'd never think it would be the chill
laid-back country where people like
grilling
you never thought it would be
melbourne to bring an end to the world's
longest lockdowns they
had the longest lockdown in the world
these people were subject to all kinds
of intrusions
privacy they had none they were pitching
all this facial recognition software
they're checking you and making sure you
have coffee in your cup if you're out
um
it is a fascist [ __ ] you can see
how easily
countries slip into
fascism
and
australia was particularly susceptible
to this because as i've said before
their population is made up
primarily of lazy and stupid criminals
which is why
they had they were susceptible not
everyone is a lazy stupid criminal i
know that
but too
many people
are over there and it allowed the
government to just trample
over
their rights and
we're going to touch on the great
resignation a little bit on the patreon
but
uh
there's something going on that's very
interesting right now uh the great
resignation has gone global i believe
the pandemic has made people think about
mortality and their life in a way that
they've never thought about it before
most people just get up every day and
they kind of you know
they don't question they just do
and they have to because that's the way
you know the system is set up
i think more and more of those people
all over the world are going what do i
want out of life and they've seen or
maybe know people that have died there
was just enough death to make you go
whoo
it wasn't it wasn't black plague level
by any means but there was enough
uncertainty and paranoia to go around
that if you're if you're a sentient
creature you had to start thinking about
the random nature of life and how weird
cruel it is and that means you say to
yourself
what
should i be doing
am i wasting my time here at houlihans
am i wasting my time
at restaurant chain
houlihans
i might be
maybe i should not spend my entire life
working at
hula get up houlihan i don't know what
this is i'm googling this
hula hands
get the menu up
who's hungry
you go to hula hands there's just a
woman eating a french onion soup and
she's lifting it up so you can see how
much cheese they put on top they won't
let me look at the menu until i tell
them where i am just tell them anywhere
i'm jonesboro arkansas great
see
so there are people right now that are
working at houlihans
go to the appetizers you want apps okay
yeah for lunch yeah okay
and those people every day are not being
paid what they want
and they have to say
do you want to try houlihan's famous
shrooms
and people go what is that and you go
it's panko crusted and garlic herb cream
cheese stuffed mushrooms with a creamy
horseradish sauce
and some people go no i don't want that
and they're in a rush
and they're just having a first dinner
with their kid
since you know the breakup was announced
and
people go i don't want to do this
i don't want to work at a theme
restaurant
i don't want to tell people about
houlihan's famous shrooms i
want more out of life and you got to
support those people but you also have
to get a cup of coffee in less than an
hour
so how do you do that how do you wrestle
with those things i want people to fully
realize their dreams but i also want
them to understand that dreams aren't
real and we live in hell
but i want people to to really try to go
after what they want but i also want to
get in and out of starbucks in less than
an hour and a half
somebody has to work at starbucks
is that are they here i think i heard
someone i'm not sure well we're wrapping
up anyway there's a lot of really good
podcasts record here very successful
people um
so that's my whole thing and that's what
we're going to go into on the patreon
wrestling with those two things between
i want people
like some of the here's what it is some
of the slave owners probably liked the
hymns
and they would sit on the porch and go
the music is beautiful
but the field needs to get play so it's
a weird
we're in a weird time goodbye